the Trump administration has achieved a
lot in just 500 days record low
unemployment a booming economy the
appointment of Neil Gorsuch and
countless other originalist judges to
the federal courts and about to be more
originalist judges because breaking news
Anthony Kennedy is retiring from the
Supreme Court the troubled ministration
is also finally moved the US Embassy in
Israel to Jerusalem gave all Americans
significant tax relief has slashed the
federal bureaucracy the list goes on and
on but the past few days have confirmed
president Trump's most incredible
political achievement of all he's making
Democrats honest again Democrats from
the New York Times op-ed page all the
way up to the halls of Congress and the
Supreme Court are now openly advocating
censorship electing self-described
socialists demanding the abolition of
law enforcement and calling for mob
terror against political opponents and
their children Democrats have not been
this honest since they started a war to
keep Republicans from freeing their
slaves we will analyze what all this
means for our country's future then see
our TVs Gavin McGinnis joins to discuss
whether the u.s. is headed for civil war
finally the similarities between
President Trump and Elvis Presley as we
analyze lessons for Republicans from
Elvis's 1968 comeback special on this
day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today we have so much
to talk about we will get to this
breaking news this finally came out that
Anthony Kennedy is retiring from the
Supreme Court this could upset the
balance of four and a half to four and a
half because Kennedy has been the sort
of swing vote though this term has been
great we will analyze all of that a ton
a ton to get to because just this week
Democrats have shown their hand Donald
Trump made them do it and the the
Supreme Court case that came out today
is aptly named Janice because we've got
a god of doors of gates to faces the
country could go in one of two
directions we'll analyze with a Canadian
Gavin McGinnis to see which way it's
gonna go
before we get to that we got to make a
little money honey we got to talk about
AIG travel guard it's really important
you know I'm gonna be traveling I am
gonna be traveling pretty soon message
and data rates may apply please do not
text and drive insurance on for by
trouble guard group bank and
underwritten by National Union Fire
Insurance Company of Pittsburgh PA for a
complete description of the coverage
limitations and exclusions go to travel
guard comm this ad does not describe
actual events and is used for
illustrative purposes only I couldn't
have said that better myself I felt he
really got that across I'm gonna be
traveling soon and I'm not gonna say
where yet but it'll be fun there'll be
some cool appearances going on but I am
NOT gonna get caught again as I have
been in the past not taking that travel
insurance because look summers coming up
you're gonna be doing a lot of traveling
I have been caught before getting
absolutely demolished on travel
insurance I've gotten I've traveled for
friends weddings things like that and I
have just gotten caught because I've
lost thousands of dollars not having
that travel insurance don't be caught
like that if you're a big planner you
know the don't miss for just a little
bit not too much money an entire trip
everything could go wrong travel guard
staff is available 24/7 to help you can
get coverage for as low as $30 when you
text mi CH AE L to 48 48 48 I'm telling
you I know you get you make your plans
and then you don't take that insurance
you don't know how it works AIG travel
guard you need it are you going to lose
some money like I did coverage includes
flight hotel rebooking flight
cancellation interruption or delay lost
or delayed baggage medical expenses and
Accu Asian passport or ticket
replacement assistance and more if any
of those things ever happened to you I
think they have don't get caught get
coverage now for just $30 text michael
mi CH AE l - 48 48 48 that is mi CH AE l
- 48 48 48 mi CH AE l - 48 48 48 I'll
save you a bunch of money don't say I
never did nothing for you in the old
days it was pretty easy to look at
Democrats and Republicans to look at the
difference in the old days
Democrats were pretty honest you know
they started this entire civil war we my
guess we might have another one coming
up but the first time they started that
civil war its but they said look we want
to keep our slaves and Republicans are
trying to free the slaves so that okay
we stand for this we stand for that
they're all terrible things they stood
for then about a century later the
Democrats started to be a little murkier
about this and actually I got to tell
you in the 1930s the big complaint from
American political scientists political
scientists association was not that the
parties were too extreme that they were
too different but it was that they were
too similar so you couldn't really tell
you know Bill Buckley started the
conservative movement basically because
of this he said there's no difference
between Democrats and Republicans there
you know you the Barry Goldwater
campaign was for a voice not an echo
have a voice not an echo have a choice
not an echo rather but he gave a voice
to those conservatives who wanted
something different now they're being
honest again you know they elected in
Queens
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes this is an open
millennial socialist unseated one of the
top Democrats in the house and she ran
her campaign was awful and despicable
she ran on basically just socialism she
went on you know Medicare for all she
went on abolishing law enforcement all
of these terrible things but she and she
wants she unseated this top Democrat the
RNC has been capitalizing on all of this
now here is the latest ad from the RNC a
few years ago ideas
we talked about were thought to be
French ideas radical ideas extremist
ideas those ideas are now mainstream I
just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings of the country do something
about your dad's immigration practices
you feckless what uncle time but for
white women who did the point otherwise
one way you get rid of trump is a
crashing economy so please bring on the
recession when is the last time
I have thought an awful lot about
blowing up
[Music]
that's a powerful ad for those who
couldn't see it on screen at the end it
says the left and 2018 unhinged and the
better ad would be the left in 2019
dangerous because it is a real threat
they're threatening violence thriving
that's at least Maxine Waters all of
these people the the right is decrying
them right now and saying and so awful
good you're showing your true colors the
left has had this undercurrent of
violence for so so long but the
Democratic Party founded the Ku Klux
Klan it was the terrorist wing of the
Democrat Party there has been an
undercurrent of violence for a long time
it went underground for a little bit and
there were subversive organizations in
the 20th century not the least of which
were The Weather Underground these
domestic terrorists who were constantly
threatening violence against their
political opponents now it's back up
again good I'm glad you know during
during the old days they they pretended
otherwise they would they wouldn't talk
about their real motives but now Donald
Trump he's just got this magic touch he
makes these people finally be honest
it's a Herculean feat you know that the
media have followed suit by the way
as obviously we've come a long way since
Barry Goldwater called for a choice not
an echo we've got the the media now
admitting that they hate the the Trump
voters not just their political
opponents not just Donald Trump they
don't not just the Emir disagreement
they despise the people and consider
them wicked who voted for Donald Trump
here's a little look blimps of the
mainstream media individuals and
institutions we will as per Chief Jim
hopper punch some people in the face
when they see to this
there are still generations of people
older people who were born and bred and
marinated in it in that prejudice and
racism and they just have to die a lot
of his supporters believe that we are
the enemy of the American people and
that is a really really an awful
situation we are not the enemy of the
American people we love the American
people of course you do
great don't we love them by the way I
didn't show you the extra minute and a
half or two minutes of that montage it
was put together by gravy or grabby news
drew played the first half on his shows
is just too many clips of media figures
especially on cable news talking about
how these people have voted for Donald
Trump a racist evil wicked they need to
be shut up they need violence to be
threatened against them and so we had to
split it up between the two shows but of
course no why would anyone think the
media or opposed to the American people
they're enemies of the American people I
don't know with rhetoric like this and
with open calls to violence like this
some people are suggesting that we're
headed towards civil war the breaking
news today which we're gonna analyze it
in a little bit Anthony Kennedy the
swing vote on the Supreme Court stepping
down some people are saying this is the
moment if there's going to be a civil
war in the country it's because the
court is about to lose a balance that
it's had for a long time or potentially
could lose that balance to help us
analyze whether or not we're careening
towards civil war we bring on an expert
from Canada Gavin McGinnis Gavin thank
you for being here
thank you for having me sir so Gavin
listen you I know that I know that
you're from America's hat or neighbor to
the north but you're an adopted I moved
here in 1999 when am I going to be
considered an American that's that's a
real question you know there's such an
anti-immigrant fervor right now that
obviously you know I think you were
seeing the Trump backlash even in your
own personal life or we headed towards
it like you guys are like the Japanese
if there's a Korean guy who was born
there but his parents are Korean he's
never jump in the you could never be
American yeah in that accent yeah you
can never be are we going to in civil
war yeah I think we're already here it's
it's a very slow creeping Civil War like
you look at the ethnic cleansing in
South Africa
that didn't happen in an afternoon yeah
it was like the Frog boiling in water
and then everyone realized wait a minute
the farms are gone how long has this
been going on and I think we've been
seeing creeping violence since Trump won
and it's getting more and more like this
past week is intense it's an asymptote I
don't know how mathematically literate
you are but it's totally illiterate okay
well it's a thing it's a crass the big
one that's the one that goes big that's
the one that goes big and it's going big
I mean this past I was just recently
mapping out all the attacks on
conservatives not because that's the be
all and end all but it's a good little
litmus test and you map them out in its
blink with cat temp and then boink with
Tommy Lauren and then boink with
Chadwicks more and Milo and then boink
boink boink this week was Sarah Huckabee
Stan Saunders and and and who was it a
Mitch McConnell it just keeps going
going a Stephen Miller they went to his
apartment they started screaming outside
his apartment and then you go well
surely someone's gonna be raining it in
and Maxine Waters goes what are you
[ __ ] doing get out there and keep
their children away and scream no peace
no asleep come on this is the Maxine
Waters moment she's been calling for
violence since the early 90s since what
since before you even immigrated to
America and now she's gumming Angie's
like this is it we can finally you know
push back on this I've heard is that the
right has all the guns and the left are
lazy is that is that some hope for the
future and it's civil war that just
means they're gonna lose that just means
that they're doomed
that's true that let's hope for the
future I guess they don't know how to
fight have you noticed tough guys tough
guys never say we're gonna go out there
we're gonna punch people in the face
yeah Tony Soprano doesn't go it's a very
difficult situation I'm gonna go and
murder a bunch of snitches he just goes
oh it would be unfortunate if something
will happen yeah I don't know because I
don't have nothing about what happened
yeah well we're gonna sit here and we're
gonna take care of that thing about the
thing with the stuff with the guy we're
gonna go put the super Assad in the
cannoli and in the RICO case is going to
get 10 feet taller I don't know it's
combined equals Ultron
there yeah if there's any liberals out
there and you're watching us wandering
on our next step is notice when we look
at each other we sort of just go that
means you're going to be in big you know
I gotta say one of our writers Amanda
presto Giacomo she tweeted out this
picture today from some company it was
all these men wearing t-shirts smiling
big hugging each other it said that the
future is female and those are the guys
who are gonna fight us in the Civil War
yeah I've I've literally fought them
before I mean at NYU and Tifa and in New
York ante phys particularly bourgeois
they're all white they're all sons of
academics they're all skinny and we
fought them and it felt like punching
raw spaghetti like Bert bones under your
fists and then they bring in more women
to help them and you go alrighty this is
what you want this is just to remember
you or the guys here who are you know
trying to hear the what future is female
people is these anti-fog eyes that the
thing about them I noticed like in the
pre ante fat days in America when I was
at college I noticed all of the occupy
you know radical rah rah they were all
the children of hedge fund managers and
then all of the college Republicans were
there on like financial aid and
work-study and yeah so is it just like a
big they're really angry at their dads
for not being home enough as a kid and
it's really just some like psychobabble
playing out on the national stage
well what word keeps coming up with them
patriarchy patriarchy patriarchy what's
a patriarchy it's a father they are and
I'm sorry to get all Freudian but they
are mad at dad for divorcing mom and
abandoning them and by the way that's a
valid beef I agree with the impetus for
these radical aunt left lunatics I agree
with their rage but the way they're
directing it is like a spoiled child
they're acting like petulant children
and petulant children get spanked on the
bum bum this is exactly I didn't put it
quite in those terms but this is exactly
my theory on how to handle these guys is
they're like little petulant children I
had Jesse Lee Peterson on the show a
little while ago and he said basically
the same thing that
there there is this rage among the
American left because their parents are
divorced or their fathers left home or
whatever and when you look at the I'm
not saying there's a exactly a
correlation here but they do coincide
there is this total breakdown of the
family huge increase in divorce rate for
the the parents of these young people
now fathers leaving the home a ton of
out of wedlock birth is this basically
just the flip side of that social
conservative argument you know the
society starts at the family and if you
have a breakdown of the family you're
gonna have a breakdown of society III
think you can link it to pretty much
anything I think it's the reason there's
a disproportionate number of blacks
involved in crime I think it's the the
idle hands of welfare which shattered
the black family and left these single
mothers with nothing to do no discipline
and so these kids get bored blacks
committed crimes about the same as
White's back before welfare took up
Thomas whole Thomas all the time if you
and I were sitting in the projects all
day just smoking pot in the lobby until
the postman couldn't see where the the
little steel boxes are cuz it's like fog
down there and that's a true story
yeah I swear to God I would get up to
mischief I'd be like you wanna learn how
to hotwire a car like you want to throw
we used to do that as teenagers we throw
bricks out of cars out of boredom this
this expanded adolescence is going up to
30's and 40's with third generation
welfare these kids are getting into
crime so that's linked to fatherlessness
I think the trinitarios in New York
murdering people's link to
fatherlessness I think that these
petulant Brad screaming I hate it here I
hate America and storming upstairs and
slamming their door so hard that their
little nameplate I'm never talking to
you again I never I hate all of you we
obviously can't handle the gangsters and
say get back downstairs or something but
as far as the the bourgeoisie who are
mad at us like these guys saying punch
people in the face we have to protect
them from themselves because these
people they don't want the universe that
they claim to want like look at gender
for example say you would let them
handle gender what's it up to now like
72 I have 468 genders I believe
I checked this morning on Drudge I don't
know if it's increased since then we
have this thing in my family called kids
day once a year and there's no rules
whatsoever you could murder someone it's
like the purge like it's the purge and
that's how I lost my wife actually
myself I'm so sorry to hear that yeah
it's gotta be really hard oh my god but
um they eat candy for dinner and they
stay up watching movies so four in the
morning and the next day they are dead
to the world and miserable and what
we're doing with the left and what
Obama's entire administers his entire
terms were was a giant kids day and
these kids are obese with candy and
they're gonna kill themselves if they if
you let them keep going though they'll
candy themselves today that's true there
we've got to raise them up we've got to
try to raise them up right and you see
it although I mean all in the New York
Times right now all the way from the New
York attention of the Supreme Court
they're talking about how we can't have
any free speech free speech is bad we
can't let conservatives talk only I can
talk oh stop shut up stop that's all
you're getting
all the time from the left is there any
way to raise them up I mean it's just a
soft saddle stop like you know when a
homeless man comes into the bar and that
21 year old who just started drinking a
bar engages him and you go thanks buddy
now we have a crazy person with us for
the rest of them you don't engage them
and we have to stop giving the left
credit we have to stop trying to debate
them and trying to listen them the
answers just know sit down like it was
beautiful with Trump when they said
there's some journals from Univision
he's like excuse me Senor
can you stop saying it ain't got babies
it's offensive and Trump is like oh I'm
sorry what would you like me to say you
had no idea by the way any future dream
latina real American citizen
undocumented baby of the person and
sometimes what that takes too long I'm
saying thank you baby we have to have
what do you how many genders do you
think they're about four hundred and
seventy now we're not doing that there's
a I'm gonna still one-to-one if you so
greedy I would have said three but no
let's stop giving these people crazy
would you get I'm gonna stop this car
and turn it right around if you want
four more genders that's it - that's all
you get
Kevin my dad would just slam on the
brakes on the highway you've given me a
lot of hope for the fees a little
nervous about that Civil War coming up
but you've really given me some hope for
the future
you know kids day is over the candy is
all unwrapped it's all gone
now it's time to be grown-ups again and
we're not going to engage the drunk guy
at the bar think of it as a child civil
war what if all the eight-year-olds were
to rise up today to take over the
country you just go oh well got a punch
some kids I feel really bad I never
thought my life would go and join this I
hate myself kind of but if it's got to
be done it's gonna mess with this for a
long-ass time but it's this you know
Gavin this seems to me to be part and
parcel of your long-standing political
philosophy coming back from one of the
greatest video works you've ever
produced wrestling your baby yeah this
has been coming up for a long time this
America Trump's America is basically a
giant nation of baby wrestling so put on
your baby wrestling gear here we are
Gavin I gotta let you go that that
really paints a picture where right now
we're at Janice you know we're at the
gate to the future and all I see is just
wrestling babies Gavin McGinnis you can
get them on CR TV get off my lawn you
get them everywhere though Gavin stuff
is some of the best and funniest
commentary out there Gavin thanks for
being here thank you have anybody let's
see it I don't even know why I you know
sometimes I prepare notes when I talk to
people but then if if Gavin's coming on
I just say okay well let's see where
this is gonna go so the good news is the
good news about all of this I by the way
I agree with most of what he just said
especially with the baby wrestling
because the American people are
responding
you know the mainstream media there just
want crying and whining and everything's
awful rending their garments and
gnashing their teeth and yet there is a
new poll out today from Axios and
SurveyMonkey which shows that the
majority of Americans all Americans not
just Republicans not just conservatives
believe that the mainstream news media
regularly and intentionally published
fake news so the 72% total of all
Americans polled in this poll say
the mainstream news media CNN ABC NBC
New York Times Washington Post regularly
publish falsehoods in their reporting
now this number when you look at just
the GOP the Republican Party is 92% or
rises to almost all of them 79 percent
of independents
so the vast vast majority of
independents and even this is the kicker
the majority of Democrats believe that
the majority of self-described Democrats
53 percent believe that the mainstream
news media regularly published lies lies
intentional falsehoods so it seems that
they're not really being fooled there is
something that we fall into here which
is a moral equivalence a totally false
moral equivalence you know that if
everybody is extreme this side hates
this side and this side hits this side
and it's all the same and it's all bad
hey we can blame Republicans and
Democrats they're all it's all about
basically the same no no it isn't the
same it isn't the left is to blame they
are to blame if there is blame to go
around the lion's share of it belongs on
the left and with the Democrats on the
one side of these issues we're talking
about particularly free speech today
you've got but even you know national
sovereignty all of these important
questions on the one side you have the
Supreme Court you have the law you have
the will of the American people you have
the the American tradition on the other
side you have the mainstream media and
Democrat politico's the mainstream media
who regularly tell lies in the Democrat
politico's who are inciting violence
those are the two sides pick your side
those are not morally equivalent not
even close so you know you've got
Alexandra Ocasio Cortes she's coming out
she is a socialist I you know at least
it's honest but these issues are coming
to an head and they're coming to a head
at the Supreme Court so the Supreme
Court now is the epicenter that's why
this breaking news today about Anthony
Kennedy is so important he's the swing
vote right he's the guy who nominally
sort of a conservatives should not
really a textualist he wrote that
basically romantic poetry and the
overage fell decision the the gay
marriage decision that had nothing to do
with the Constitution and but why are
all these issues fought out at the
Supreme Court one it's because this is
in though in the government the the
American government follows basically
Detroit
bipartite soul so the logos pathos and
ethos the logical part the emotional
part and the spirited part so the the
logical part is the court you know
they're just analyzing the logic of the
law the the emotional part is the
Congress obviously they're totally
responsive to the will of the people and
then the spirited part is the executive
it's supposed to embody the American
nation and sort of wield the American
nation to execute the laws and policies
of the United States the philosophical
battles are being fought at the
philosophical place but part of the read
there used to be fought in other places
as well the reason they're being fought
there is because the legislature and the
presidency have both given up a lot of
their power they've said well we don't
want to deal with this we don't yet
especially the Congress has given up so
much of its power we don't want to do
the Supreme Court can rule even past
presidents have said I don't know if
this is constitutional but we'll let the
Court decide and President Bush said
this when he signed mccain-feingold said
I don't know if this is constitutional
but well the court will decide no it's
your job to decide to you were supposed
to engage in these philosophical battles
for the country but they've given up
their power so now we've we see these
what a great week what a great month for
Supreme Court decisions great decisions
on free speech with regard to religious
liberty with regard to abortion with
regard to life national sovereignty and
who can come into the country who gets
to decide who leaves the kind who is
able to enter and travel and now a labor
labor Liberty you know the the ability
if you are working for in the public
sector for the government that you can
decide I am NOT going to pay my union
dues for this political speech I don't
have to have my speech compelled that's
the big case that came out Janis versus
the American Federation of State County
Municipal Employees so this guy Marc
Janis is a public employee he doesn't
want to pay his union dues he doesn't
want his money going to politics he
disagrees with he doesn't want to
participate in that speech that he
doesn't believe in can the government
force him to into compelled speech now
first of all public sector unions are a
force government unions and private
unions are totally different entities in
the private union you've got the
employer and you've got the employees
and there's a tug of war there's a
battle here and that each has something
to lose each has
thing to gain so it's sort of a fair
fight when it comes to the government
the public sector unions the government
is just negotiating with itself
it's just negotiating with its own
entities so the people who elect them
the unions that give them money it's oh
it who loses the American taxpayer loses
the American people lose but there's
neither have anything to gain by with by
not raising rates by not raising giving
in to labor demands so this question was
do government employees have have to
have their speech compelled and it's
really you know all nature is but art
unknown today in all chances direction
which thou canst not see the name here
Janus is so important Janus is the Roman
god the two-faced Roman god of gates of
beginnings and of ends and it really
feels like we're at the end of something
and maybe at the beginning of something
we're in a gate here the country can go
one of two ways
all of these Supreme Court decisions
have been great because they've cleared
away a lot of the muck all of the
tyrannical oppressive yucky muck but now
the question is do Americans want
Liberty do we want freedom freedom has
costs freedom has risks freedom leave
some people behind if if they if they
don't push themselves if they can't
succeed if they take risks and lose do
Americans still have the will for
freedom the the left in this country
adamantly says no they're pushing for a
medicare-for-all and I always thought
when I heard Medicare for all I thought
that's the worst campaign slogan I've
ever heard
Medicare for all that makes it sound
like we're all just old geriatric
helpless people you know to can't fend
for ourselves and but that's what
they're running on they say we want you
to be helpless we want we're gonna take
care of you baby baby we're inish it's
okay it's okay and that's what they're
pushing for you know that that election
and queens they're they're being honest
now they're saying we're full-on
socialists we don't like the country we
don't like law enforcement we're just
good hey let us let us be your
benevolent betters your dictators and
then it's not just these wacko
candidates all the way from the op-ed
page of the New York Times to the
Supreme Court the left is saying you
should not have the right to speech you
should not have the right to speech
that's what elena kagan left-wing
justice on the court she had a
blistering dissent
in the Janus case this is what she wrote
today is not the first time the court
has wielded the First Amendment in such
an aggressive way and it threatens not
to be the last speech is everywhere a
part of every human activity employment
health care securities trading you name
it
for that reason almost all economic and
regulatory policy effects or touches
speech so the majority's road runs long
and at every stop or black-robed rulers
overriding citizens choices the First
Amendment was meant for better things
are you kidding me it's so I mean this
argument which is about choice do people
get to have a choice that's what the
Janis case is about do people get to
have the choice to join the union or not
to join the union to pay union dues or
not to pay union dues and she's saying
that that that having that choice is the
opposite of choice I mean this is
Orwellian stuff war is peace up is down
that's what she's saying but but listen
to what she says she says you know
speech is involved in a lot of human
activities
you don't say Sherlock is that is that
right speech isn't because the speech
it's the First Amendment it's the first
one it's not like the eighth amendments
the First Amendment the founders clearly
thought it was important and every
civilization in the history of the world
has said that speech is the essential
human activity Genesis in Genesis the
the primal act of creation the act that
creates the cosmos is an act of speech
the Lord says let there be light the the
in Christianity the the Savior is the
Word of God is the speech
what does Adam do his job that God gives
him is to name things to use his speech
to order the world in in Gilgamesh the
the rising up from the animal from the
brutal and the animalistic to the human
is to gain speech because speech is
consciousness and it's not just ancient
myths it's modern social science you
know modern linguistics Noam Chomsky
whom I rarely cite in the affirmative
but he's good on linguistics he says
that a recursive language is what
defines human consciousness that's what
makes a human a human is the ability to
have language to have words and speech
this is the essential human activity and
Kagan is saying yeah but if we let
people have freedom over their speech
they're gonna have a lot of freedom we
can't have that
oh we can't have no no no speech is too
important to humanity we have to
restrict that we have to bring that down
and it's a it's a really sick and
insidious argument but that is the
argument of the left now this was in the
the New York Times op-ed page and I'm
gonna have to sign off this was in the
op-ed page today I believe today or
yesterday the the question was do
ignorant ignorant people don't have the
right to an audience which is funny that
the author of this op-ed got it got it
published it got a pretty big audience
there's irony abounds this was by Brian
W van Norden a philosophy professor
somewhere and the premise of the article
is that isn't it awful that Ann Coulter
gets to go on TV just liked on EEZ
Coates gets to go on TV because ton he's
e-codes he's so great he's that
absolutely shallow thinker who writes
for the Atlantic and blames everything
on race and even though he's one of the
most successful people in the country
says they you can't get ahead because of
your race it meanwhile he's won the
MacArthur Genius grant he's succeeded
beyond anyone's wildest imagination he's
saying isn't that awful that
conservatives get to talk but so do
lefties it isn't it awful that Jordan
Peterson gets to go on TV just like Kate
man gets to go on TV because Jordan
Peterson he's obviously wrong so he
shouldn't go on TV and then he quotes
mark ooza
Herbert Marcuse I was from the Frankfurt
School he as a Marxist critical theorist
and Mark ooza he's actually pilloried
and mocked in the Coen Brothers movie
Hail Caesar
the idiot character of George Clooney is
saying like well you know professor Mark
ooza said that this is all really good
and and you know what else more koozai
said and then and the joke is that
Marcus is just wrong about everything
and that's when josh brolin picks him up
and slaps him across the face so he
quotes more Kooza in this New York Times
op-ed he says quote in endlessly
dragging debates over the media the
stupid opinion is treated with the same
respect as the intelligent one the
misinformed may talk as long as the
informed and propaganda rides along with
education truth and falsehood if only we
could censor all those stupid stupid
people that's the premise right but who
gets to decide who the stupid people are
we look what the bad ideas are why
Herbert Marcuse ax of course why Brian
W van Norden of course the op-ed page of
the New York Times gets
to decide you don't get to decide
conservative people you disagree with
don't get to decide no it's just them
this is what they're pushing for you
know it's no coincidence that these
ideas particularly from our Kooza help
to inspire the the rebellions of the
1960s bombs in the streets riots
everywhere anti-establishment
anti-government protests and we're
seeing the bubble up again just as we're
seeing threats of that again there are
left wing pundits who are saying we
could have bombs in the streets that we
could have real rebellion in the country
and no coincidence that idea is a really
terrible idea there's a thought that
stops thought and that's the only
thought that ought to be stopped
we'll get into the question of what's
going to happen next when we go through
the Janus Gate the two-faced gate in a
second I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube I'm already running
long today go over to Daley wire.com why
why do you need to go you know what you
get you know what you get right you get
the shows okay you get the conversation
we've got a great fourth of July special
coming up backstage
DLE wire backstage special with Jordan
Peterson you get to ask questions you
know you get to ask questions in the
mailbag you should go over there right
now because we're gonna do that tomorrow
Anthony Kennedy is retiring pray for me
guys because I'm gonna have to take a
few big gulps here and from the Connery
over and over oh I still have two and a
half tumblers of this to finish Anthony
Kennedy is retiring and hopefully and
probably going to get an originalist in
his place I've warned you guys before
you haven't heeded my warning go to
daily wired.com right now you need to
you will be washed away I don't know if
there's gonna be a civil war but there
will be a flood and the flood will cover
all of the earth and it will last for
many many years because Anthony Kennedy
is retiring and we're getting at an
originalist justice in his place go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back and
then we'll compare Trump to Elvis
I was a little hyperbolic at the top of
the show the the last time I said the
last time the Democrats were this honest
was when we freed their slaves and they
you know then they threw a war to to try
to stop that that's not quite true the
left was pretty honest in the 1960s they
actually were pretty honest then they
would say yeah we want to overthrow the
government man we want to help the
Soviet Union man we want we want to get
rid of all of it it's all awful we want
a new morality we don't like the
traditional moral order you had The
Weather Underground the leader of which
was one of Barack Obama's political
mentors Bill Ayers you had them setting
off bombs trying to bomb government
buildings what is gonna happen with the
civil war I said yesterday I don't think
it's likely to happen I think Matt Walsh
I think said this I think we all kind of
agree it's unlikely that's gonna happen
because this Gavin said the other side
is a bunch of babies and we have all the
guns but there is a new poll out that
shows that 31% of Americans all
Americans say that a civil war is likely
within the next five years eleven
percent say it's very likely and this
this holds equally basically among
Democrats and Republicans Democrats are
more likely to think a civil war is
coming that's thirty seven percent
compared to thirty two percent of
Republicans independents about a quarter
of them say that civil war is likely and
by so who knows that's that's a minority
of voters but the majority of voters 59%
of people say that those opposing Donald
Trump will start violence and the reason
they're saying that is they're already
doing it it should be a hundred percent
we've seen all the videos they're saying
please go go attack their homes attack
their families chase them down in the
street so we know that that's happening
that is pretty scary that is not a good
place to be but it gets back to that
freedom argument you know I'll use John
Mort use mark Janice's name to talk
about the the god Janus the Roman god
Janus from where we get January and it
has two faces it isn't all you know when
we're so happy I mean it's like the best
two weeks of news ever all of these huge
supreme court victories real victories
for liberty Liberty is not going to die
today Anthony Kennedy the squish is
retiring we're gonna get
good textualist judge in his place we
hope I mean this is all good news but
there are two sides of that there is
going to be pushback some conservatives
have suggested that Anthony Kennedy is
the last person holding the social
fabric together because lefties can
count on him sometimes
he's a swing vote once the court becomes
solidly originalist or textualist then
democrats and the left are going to have
to admit that they are opposed to the
law they hate the law they hate the
institution of the Supreme Court and
they're gonna try to knock it down the
left is very good at destroying
institutions not good at building up
institutions but good at destroying them
that is scary there are two sides to the
Roman god Janus you know one looking
back one looking forward one looking
behind the gate looking behind you to
the to the past and one looking forward
and seeing if we can go together in a
productive way
freedom is risky you don't know how it's
going to turn out you can't predict the
future that's why it's the future you
cannot predict it but there is a chance
and we should embrace freedom because
you can see the light you know where
there's light there's hope and there is
hope for the future of the country but
you got it just march on forward you got
to keep plowing ahead even though it's
dangerous even though the leftist mobs
that Maxine Waters is calling or going
to your house and scream even though the
threats to your job threats to your
place of business threats to your family
threats to yourself you just got to keep
going forward this is what it feels like
to win you know the United States has
been through way rougher periods than
this in the civil war they had to shoot
like trained armed soldiers now we're
just wrestling with babies so he gotta I
know it still feels chaotic and rough
but these are victories there does seem
to be hope ahead the Democrats are being
honest they're showing their cars and
the American people don't like their
cards I think this does not this is not
a great strategy for the the Democrats
and we're gonna we're gonna see that
we're gonna save America it still
supports freedom or not but we can learn
a thing or two from Elvis Presley and in
my my last few minutes here on this day
in history in 1968 Elvis Presley staged
his comeback special on NBC and I think
that there are some similarities here
between Elvis and the president
obviously and but also that the
Republicans can learn a lot from that
Elvis specially in 1968 Elvis Presley
1968 comeback special so
the way this worked out I don't know if
you've ever seen it let's just play a
clip from the comeback special to show
you what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
I love Elvis I'm a huge Elvis fan I've
been an Elvis fan since I was a kid I
you know Bill Buckley even was a leftist
Aaron left an Elvis fan you know there
there is something kind of conservative
about Elvis and I just really love him
and by 1968 Elvis's career was in the
gutter I mean was so awful largely
caused by his manager Tom Parker but he
in 1956 he was the big hit rock and
roller you know the biggest thing in the
world and then he stood this string of
forgettable Hollywood movies that I sort
of enjoy but they weren't very good and
he was killing fatter and it just wasn't
he had nothing you know and so they had
this idea for a comeback special and
what his manager Tom Parker wanted was
it for it to just be one of these Andy
Williams playing Christmas carols on TV
really boring and you know that would
have been awful there was a young
executive or a young director at NBC 26
years old
Steve bender and he had a different idea
for the comeback special it was gonna be
unplugged raw honest there were gonna be
people all around him and the way they
found this he came up with this ideas he
walked into Elvis's dressing room one
night I mean was just kind of jamming
with his friends and he said this is it
this is the special this is what you
want and the most famous scenes from
that special or Elvis just playing
around with his friends people on stage
sitting around looking up at him very
casual very authentic even the moments
where it's really big onstage it's Elvis
alone vulnerable not a crowds of throng
people around him not crazy lights and
everything just really intimate and
really authentic this is what the GOP
can learn from Donald Trump because what
Donald Trump did is he took away all of
the contrived glitz and glamor and he
made his campaign as authentic as can be
I mean he talked directly to the
American people his main mode of
communication is a direct line to the
American people on Twitter it's not the
super specially produced campaign ad you
think of all the campaign ads Mitt
Romney's ever run
they're so slick they're so tight and
they're totally unpersuasive
they're awful I mean they're just bad
right and but Trump's was rough it was
something went wrong it went wrong
whatever you know and that this has been
an evolution in American media for
I mean this has been an evolution forget
just American media since Pericles gave
the funeral oration you know the
acoustics in ancient theaters were
designed such that you ideally would
maximize the volume that would travel
while still trying to remain intimate
you know you wouldn't have to scream and
shout you wouldn't have to jump around
and dance around you want that intimacy
and that authenticity you get that in
radio much better Franklin Roosevelt use
that very well
TV much much more intimate then you get
to the Internet much you're in these
really close settings where you're just
talking I'm not I'm talking to however
many people right now I'm not shouting
and screaming right it's an intimate
mode of communicating the the Republican
Party should understand this we are
winning the conservative movement has
talked and stirred something within the
American people the public opinion show
polls all show this that the public
agrees with the GOP on the vast majority
of issues even on fake news I mean the
majority of people the vast majority of
Americans agree with the GOP on
immigration you've got this woman who
won the Socialists and Queens she says
we want open borders we need open
borders we need to abolish immigration
law enforcement they're speaking to the
American people you don't need to like
do a soft-shoe about you don't need to
dance around and scream and shout the
the message will win you have to
communicate it authentically and if
really the 1968 special really made me
think about it because if Elvis had come
out and tried to do some big crazy show
no one would have cared it's how that's
sad he's trying to isn't that sad but
instead he just comes out and he's raw
and he's himself that is how we're gonna
win in the midterms that's how we're
gonna that's how we're gonna go through
the right gate of Janis and move the
country in the right direction is speak
honestly because people aren't stupid
the left thinks that people are stupid
in and gullible fools and easily
confused and easily deceived they're not
they're not people the the average
person you pick up on the street the
so-called average person that you pluck
up he's probably just as smart as you
are right there's no reason to think
that you're this great genius that is a
total prejudice of the left say we're
all the geniuses in this room and
everybody else out there
they're the unwashed masses talk to
people and respect them speak directly
to them talk fearlessly you know and
don't ignore their complaints they're
serious complaints don't ignore their
needs
don't say that their needs are wrong and
sinful and if you want to have a your
law enforced that you're a racist Nazi
awful terrible person just speak to
people directly and respectfully it's
gonna pay off all right that's it and we
got to fit Elvis into this show get your
mailbag questions and we got a lot more
coming up tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you